>> Guys. Summer is here,
and we've got 10 cool life hacks
to help you have fun in the sun.
[Captions by Jeffrey D. at Y Translator]
[Music]
TKOR: THE KING OF RANDOM
If you use loose ice
to keep all of your food cool,
you're gonna end up
with a puddle of water,
and all of your food
floating in it.
Instead of that,
use some frozen water bottles
to keep your food cool.
The ice will stay contained in the bottles,
and once it melts,
you can just drink the water
For a fun twist on a summer treat,
you can actually carbonate
many types of fruit using dry ice.
Some of my favorites are
strawberries, grapes or sliced pineapple.
Put your fruit in a cold safe container
on top of the dry ice,
separated by a piece of cardboard
to prevent excessive freezing.
Cover the box with a sheet of foil.
You don't want to use any sort of lid
that will allow the pressure
from the dry ice to build up.
After about half an hour,
the fruit will have absorbed
a lot of carbon dioxide out
of the dry ice.
It's pretty hard to see on video
the difference in the fruit.
But as you eat it,
it fizzes just like a soda.
Maybe more.
Using a watermelon,
a couple of plastic plumbing parts
and a few simple tools,
you can make a fun drink
dispenser that's sure to delight.
Tiki torches are a great
outdoor decoration,
but the standard lamp oil that they use
only burns in one color.
Try using methanol as a fuel.
Add boric acid for a green tint.
Or the lithium from
a lithium battery for magenta
Always wear gloves
when you're handling the lithium
Don't let it get wet.
And if you're going to be
burning the fuel
Make sure you're doing it
somewhere outside
where you won't be
breathing in the fumes.
Yogurt is a delicious summertime treat
But there can be a couple
frustrating things about it.
The first is its tendency to squirt out
some yogurt as you peel back the foil
By lifting up the foil
with the edge of the spoon
All of the escaping yogurt
will be caught right where you need it
Occasionally, you may find
after finishing a cup of yogurt
that your spoon is too heavy
and you can't get it to stay up.
To avoid getting yogurt on your table,
and keep your cup from tipping,
simply turn your spoon upside down.
The redistribution of weight
should make it stay up.
If you're a big fan of Wendy's frosties,
but don't live anywhere
near one of the restaurants.
Here's a simple recipe
you can follow to make your own.
Start with 2 cups of chocolate milk
3 tablespoons of sweetened
condensed milk
and if you want to add
just a little bit extra
that's not going to hurt.
Add 1 tablespoon of malted milk powder
Finally, add one cup of Cool Whip.
Mix together until it's all smooth.
If you own an ice cream making machine
you can easily pour
the whole concoction into that
and let it sit for
about 15 to 20 minutes.
If not, you can pour
all this into a Ziploc bag
surround that bag
with ice and salt in a larger bag
and mix it up until it's
the consistency you want.
If you're ever on a road trip,
and wondering how long
it is til you arrive.
Just look for signs that say
how many miles it is to the next city.
When you see a sign
that says distance to your city,
take the number of miles times 60,
then divide it by
your speed in miles per hour
to get the time remaining.
For example,
if it's 35 miles to the next city,
multiply that times 60,
and you'll get 2100.
Divide 2100 by 80 miles per hour,
and you get 26.25
which is the number of minutes.
Just over 26 minutes until
you arrive at your destination.
Of course, most people
these days have GPS
but it's a cool trick to know
just in case you don't.
Ice does a great job
of keeping drinks cold
But if you're really in a hurry
to cool down a can or a bottle,
it works a lot better
to use ice, salt and water.
The ice by itself
measures a temperature
of about 32...
maybe 33 degrees Fahrenheit.
Whereas the ice with
the water and the salt on it
is measuring a chilly
21 degrees Fahrenheit.
You can see that after
only about two minutes,
the can in the salty ice water
is almost 10 degrees colder
than the can in the ice alone.
We don't just have to rely
on the thermometer,
let's give it a taste test.
Noticeably cooler,
doesn't really seem like
it just came out of the fridge though.
Ice and salt water.
Noticeably colder and it only
took about two minutes.
You've used plenty
of lighter fluid
but your barbecue charcoal
is still taking too long to light
Shorten your prep time
by using the blower function
on a shopvac,
a hair dryer
or if you don't have electricity
a simple balloon pump.
These balloon pumps are great
because they work as a bellows
that push air out on both
the pull and the push.
If you're looking for a way to keep your
drinks cold without watering them down.
Try freezing a few different
types of soda
Fruit-flavored ice cubes work pretty well
in all the fruit flavored sodas.
And I find that cream soda works well
in all the other flavors
Creamy.
Hey guys
Thanks for watching.
If you're not a subscriber yet,
just hit the bomb to get in the club.
If you missed our last video
or want to see it again,
click up here at the top.
Click down there if you want to see
what the internet thinks
that you should watch next.
That's it for now.
Have fun, be safe,
and see you tomorrow.